the more detail you get on John
fetterman the sadder you feel for John
fetterman he does seem in some ways like
the victim here
that's what the evidence shows so
fetterman you'll remember was elected to
the U.S Senate with the help of lying
media organizations who told us he was
fine and you didn't like disabled people
if you had questions about his condition
but he wasn't fine at all it was the
opposite of fun he shouldn't have been
there we know that because immediately
after taking office he was hospitalized
for depression
an interview with CBS News yesterday
fetterman explained that while he was at
Walter Reed Medical Center doctors
identified another issue with his health
watch
when I talk what do you hear I hear you
talking and I can understand much of
what you're saying what you're saying
but my hearing has the deficiency that
that makes it difficult for me to fully
understand 100 of it
so he doesn't fully understand
everything that he's hearing well that
seems like a problem for him personally
also for the country since he's one of a
hundred Senators but CBS wasn't worried
at all instead they asked the natural
question are you going to run for
president
can you have aspirations can you serve
beyond the United States Senate you know
my aspiration is to take my son to the
restaurant that we were supposed to go
during his birthday but couldn't because
I had checked myself in for depression
and being the kind of dad the kind of
husband uh and the the the kind of
Senator that Pennsylvania deserves you
know that's truly that's what my
aspiration is
so that seems honestly like a more
normal aspiration taking your boy to a
restaurant but CBS News wants him to run
for president you can't overstate how
repulsive a lot of journalists are most
Dr Mark Siegel joins us tonight to
assess what we saw in this interview
doctor what do you think of this Tucker
first of all I can't believe that she
asked him if he's running for president
even before the depression the chances
of him surviving the term are less than
50 percent from the kind of stroke he
had and he has a bad heart then we find
out that he's had chronic depression
which nobody told told the the voters of
Pennsylvania about he's been suffering
it for years on the positive side I
thought that he was good coming forward
and saying I couldn't get out of bed I
didn't want to eat I was losing weight I
had no happiness in my life I couldn't
celebrate my son's 14th birthday and I
had to be hospitalized because
depression is a disease that so often
stigmatized and over 10 percent of
Americans suffer from severe depression
so in saying that he makes it less
stigmatized on the other hand what was
he doing in the hospital for six weeks
the usual hospitalization is six to ten
days how come if he's being transparent
we're not finding out what the treatment
was there and you just pointed out
there's issues with hearing that's
related to his stroke you know there's
the issue of that he has a 60 chance or
more of recurrent depression that he
goes back in the hospital all of which
leads me to my main point we feel bad
for him we like that he came forward we
feel compassion for him on a personal
level but what about the voters of
Pennsylvania what about this the 14
million people in Pennsylvania what
about the people in the United States
who have a senate that's so divided that
every vote matters and is he up to
voting is he fit to serve I have serious
serious concerns about that and so
should every American Tucker that's
exactly that's exactly right Dr Mark
Siegel thank you so much thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight